hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
here and I'm excited to tell you about
the recent upgrade that we made to the
orderflows Delta scalper that I think is
just going to blow your mind now the
Delta scalper allows you to see positive
or negative expansion between buyers and
sellers so that you can take lowrisk
trades in the market and since its first
release in 2016 we have made several
upgrades to isolate the highest
probability trades you know we've added
uh price action to it we've added
momentum to it and over the last 6
months we've been working on an upgrade
in the programming for the Delta scalper
and what it is it's multi-timeframe or
chart analysis and the results have
really been
outstanding now the Delta scalper is a
tool like I said designed to pick up
potential shifts in supply and demand
which are caused by big orders getting
filled in the market that otherwise may
go unnoticed you know in other words
there a way to pick up Iceberg orders
you know Everyone likes to talk about
icebergs nowadays and think about it you
know we released this indicator in 2016
when just a few people were
understanding what icebergs are but now
everyone talks about icebergs you know
which are big orders that have hidden
quantities behind it and if you look at
um you know the the depth of Market or
you know even a a market heat map or or
book map you only see what people want
you to see in the sense of they're
showing you know part of their order but
of course once the order trades then
that volume shows up in the volume of
course right it has to by The Exchange
and by the rules of trading you know
once the trade happens it's prints and
the Delta scalper is a tool that picks
up on that hidden volume once it trades
because once it trades it's not hidden
anymore right and the Delta scalper is a
tool that you could add to your trading
without having to use a volume footprint
chart unless you want to you know some
people like to trade just off of
Candlestick charts and that's fine Delta
scalper was designed to run on
Candlestick charts but again you know
many orderflow Traders use it with their
footprint chart as well and like I said
the upgrade deals with higher time
frames right it deals with multi- uh you
know time frames compared to now so
let's understand the order flow on
higher time frames and why it's crucial
for short short-term Traders right
because Delta scalper again is about um
taking points out of the market you know
when they present themselves and why you
should look for higher time frame
signals on Lower time frame charts and
what I mean by that is you know if you
trade a one minute chart you can now
look at signals on the Delta scalper for
a 5minute chart for a 10minute chart for
a 15minute chart you know it's up to you
now the reason why higher time frames
are important is because higher time
frame Trends are longer and harder to
reverse bigger moves are likely to
originate from higher time frame levels
right I mean if if a move is you know on
a higher time frame you know technically
it's going to be
stronger price can take more time to
resolve the higher time frame levels and
what that means is it can take more time
to reverse a higher time frame frame
level dominant trend is more reliably
derived from a higher time frame chart
you know as much as I love to read
orderflow about what's happening right
now if there was a way you know I always
you know over the years I say there's a
way I wish I could just I could also see
signals from the higher time frame in
the orderflow without having to sit
through an hourong chart of a footprint
cuz you know it it there's a lot of data
and it's hard you know the nice thing is
about the computer is it does that
analysis for you and what Delta scalper
does now it has the ability to do it's
going to do that hourly well I would I
don't use hourly I use 15 minutes uh 5
minute 10 minute and even sometimes I
will look at 30 minute uh time frames
and it's going to put it on my one
minute chart that I trade so imagine you
know I could be clued in on something
that's happening on a 30 minute chart on
my one minute chart I can jump in and
scalp it okay again you know generally
higher time frame Trends last longer
than lower time frame Trends okay and
this should be self-evident but it's
easily forgotten because you know if
you're looking at a move on a 30 minute
chart it's probably going to be a bigger
move than on a one minute chart but if
you can take that information from the
30 minute chart say Hey you know a a
move is happening on this 30 minute
chart put it the signal on your one
minute chart you know I think that's
very
powerful now again like I said you know
the problem that I faced with trying to
analy iyz orderflow on a higher time
frame was sitting through a higher time
frame footprint you know it's honestly
it's excruciating trying to sit through
a 30 minut if you're a short-term Trader
like me it's excruciating trying to sit
through a 15 minute a 30 minute
footprint chart waiting for it to form
so you you know you could figure out
your analysis because you know often
times with those longer time frames
things change dramatically within you
know just that time period
okay now with enre time frame you know
there there's no need to be entirely
uniform in time selection and what I
mean by that is you know if you want to
use a you know 15 minute a 20 minute a
30 minute you know it's up to you right
you can put all those signals on your
chart so if a higher time frame
structure is doing its job then the
lower time frame structure is unlikely
to reverse right cuz think of the higher
time frame as the bigger brother to the
lower time frame right and we all know
generally at least in my family
um the higher you know the older kid
bullies the younger kid um you know the
younger kid may have a lead for a little
while and but the higher time frame is
going to take over now the best setups
are when the higher time frame and the
lower time frame are aligned and what
that means is you know if the higher
time frame obviously is going up lower
time frames going up that's going to be
your best trade you know and you hear it
all the time with Traders oh you know I
like to do the top down approach I I
start at the weekly chart the daily
chart the 4H hour chart the 1 hour chart
15-minute chart and waiting for it all
to be aligned now you can sort of do it
on a smaller level right you could take
you could take a 15-minute chart maybe
or a 5 minute chart align it with your
one minute chart okay but really let's
go look at the charts I think that's
going to give you um you know the best
idea of what I'm talking about now let
me just uh dig up my charts here because
you know it's it's one thing to talk
about it but when you can see it in real
time so this is the e- minis you know a
1 minute chart okay and this is the
footprint chart and be honest you know
reading
it okay you know if you're skilled in
order flow you know you can you you like
looking at this chart but I'll be honest
a lot of people don't like to look at a
at a footprint chart that's just the way
it is um you know they get scared by the
big numbers but really there's a lot of
good information in a footprint chart so
the Delta scalper will run on the
footprint chart as well as a bar chart
which I'll jump to in a second but
really you know the Delta scalpers based
off of reading the Delta numbers at the
bottom which is the difference between
the aggressive buyers and the aggressive
Sellers and you know when you have start
seeing expansion one way or the other
either positive or negative positive
would be you know the aggressive Traders
taking over and starting to dominate and
expansion to the downside you know being
aggressive sellers are taking over right
and the Delta scalper will draw a zone
out from there if it's not retested
immediately and it'll stop drawing the
zone out but more importantly it'll draw
the up triangle for the Buy Signal the
down triangle for the sell signal okay
and again it's a great tool to
complement uh a footprint chart
especially if you're new to reading
order flow it's a way to sort of fast
track your way to understanding order
flow because it's going to again you can
start by watching the Delta seeing
what's happening and sort of start to
learn you know the importance of tools
like Delta okay but like I said you know
we've added um a few new tools over the
years or not tools but rather um you
know new things on the Delta scalper
that will help traders to take better
trades right we got swing filter so if
you want to just see signals at swing
highs or swing lows um you can do that
the positive Delta strength as well and
negative Delta strength keep them
aligned one and one is the
base which most people are going to use
you can go a little bit higher two and
two or three and three now one thing to
note with that is it's not an
incremental change it's it's a double
it's a double and then a double again so
if you go from 1 to two you know the
strength that you're looking at you know
think of it like this if
uh positive Delta strength you know say
say the base you know say the number was
10 if you go from 1 to two on your Delta
strength it goes from a reading of 10 to
20 and then if you
go to three it's not 10 20 30 it's 10 20
40 the 20 is now doubled but for most
people um just one is fine one you know
one two or three is is the most you're
going to going to go up
three momentum strength right if you
want to be trading in the direction of
the market meaning you're trading in the
momentum you know you can set it between
one and six actually zero would be to
disable it three is middle of the road
it's average I to me that's that's what
I use is three okay now if you're using
the swing filter obviously you're going
to want to turn off the momentum
strength because if you're trying to
isolate swing highs or swing lows um
you're trying to isolate a reversal so
you're not looking for momentum now the
new thing that we've added in here is
this one period type okay and you can
change it to tick volume range second
minute okay so like I was saying you
know if you want to change it to you
keep your underlying base chart a 15 uh
sorry a one minute chart but you want to
look at signals on a 15-minute chart you
would do that say you want to um base it
off volume all right this is e- minis
you know I don't know what you use for E
minis you some people like to look at e
Minis on a 10,000 range uh 10,000 volume
chart you know then you just type in
10,000 okay maybe you want to do it on
5,000 okay um you can even do you know
seconds you can go below your chart so
if your charts a one minute you know
maybe you want to do 5 Seconds you're
going to get a lot of signals that way
you can do range you know if you want to
see the signals on your one minute chart
based off of a 10 range chart you could
same with
tick right so you want to say you
know 2,000 ticks or something you know
you just change it there then click
apply
now let's just jump to really quick
um a simple bar chart here okay
now the reason why I'm going to jump to
a bar chart because it's it's a little
bit easier
to see it develop on a bar chart okay so
this is a bar chart now again this is
you know this is e- minis today I'm
recording this what day is today today's
the 19th it's about 7 in the morning not
7 in the morning 9:30 in the morning I
woke up at 7:00 um and you can see right
here this is where the cash opened up
here and it's kind of choppy okay it's
not really doing a whole heck of a lot
right now okay so you know earlier in
the day there was some decent moves
right doesn't look like much but it's
actually a pretty decent range from you
know this low here is what is that
68 and a half you know all the way up to
04 so you know it's almost a 35 Point
range and if let's just go back to the
indicator settings okay so this is set
on a 5 minute chart now if I was just
using the base chart
meaning you know the one minute chart I
would just keep it at chart the default
would come up chart and zero right this
is what the default is going to look
like when you first well here let me
just show you really quick um add it
here Delta scalper okay these are the
defaults chart and period value is zero
so that means that will it will read the
underlying chart chart trade entry
signals turned
on no swing filter enabled positive
Delta negative Delta is one momentum
strength is three and you're going to
see there there's by itself right this
is the up until today this is how the
Delta scalper um worked it didn't have
this from time frame this is the new
addition is the is the F from time frame
and it does give decent signals you know
a lot of Traders use it they're very
happy with it okay they have their ways
of using it but you can see here right
yeah it's nice there's a lot more
signals even here you're getting some
signals and you know for a lot of
Traders they're fine with that now what
I'm saying is what we've done is we've
added you know because at same time you
know while I'm happy with a lot of the
signals there's still some that I'm I'm
not happy with okay you know I'm not
happy with the cell here not happy with
the cell here um
you know and adding a different
dimension to it is okay so again what
we're going to do is we're going to
change it to from the basic one minute
chart but I want to see how it's you
know how these higher time frames are
you know basically are reacting to this
Market okay you know we'll start with
the five all right five
minutes okay because that that's the
chart that actually I showed you when I
when I pulled it up
okay and then you know we're going to
compare we'll take a look at other
markets as as
well you know we'll take a look at crude
because I know it's crude you know
people always ask me about M andq um you
know some of the currencies Euro
currency you know we'll look at mini do
we'll look at some different markets
with different settings so you could
truly
understand how important this this new
upgrade is so okay yeah you know I got a
sell here a sell here I'm not happy with
that but now I got this nice buy here
another nice buy here okay um you know
even if I was going to look at you know
some of the previous days you I don't
know what happened here with Ninja
missing a big chunk of
data but if you just look back at some
of these previous days right sell here
right nice sell there nice sell there um
you know just going back and again you
know here even started earlier
overnight you know it just gave you know
right off you know 7:30 there was your
Buy your body here did pull back now we
do draw these zones out from when the
Delta scalper signal first appeared yeah
that is your sort of your Line in the
Sand your stop for you know when you're
taking a
trade okay CU people always ask you know
how do I get long where do I put my stop
that's why we have these zones drawn out
okay but again you know I'm just
choosing in these examples you know five
minutes you know you could if you don't
like five minutes you you want to do 10
minutes you can you know if you want to
use um you know
different you know volume or or tick
it's really it's really powerful okay
I'll just just leave it that let's take
a look at at crude oil okay now this is
crude
today right you see the Buy Here Sell
here it's a buy where went sideways
catch this nice move down again you know
sometimes on these charts it doesn't
look like much but still you know we're
talking a move from 75 down to 25 it's a
50c move there you know even here is a
nice move this is what the type of chart
this is still my 5 minute
chart okay um you know
if you know you want to use you know
again that's that's a three minute
signal sorry five minute if I want to do
you know you can change it to whatever
minutes you want 3 minutes 10 minutes 15
minutes you know it's it's um quite
interesting here right you're seeing the
cells here sell came in higher here
there's a short here there's a buy long
here um you know just even going back
you know previous day right this nice
move down from 30 8137 down into 70s
this move up here um you
know if you want to take a look
at we'll go to tick we'll just go
through these tick I don't know it's a
good tick to use in crude you know
200 now if if you watch the markets long
enough right you generally have your
favorite markets that you like to trade
okay and you understand that you know
you should understand you know a 200
tick chart might be equivalent to around
a a one minute chart or you know if you
ticks it's the amount of Trades that
take place now a trade could be one
contract it could be a 100 contracts but
it's the amount of Trades but generally
speaking
um you know if if you're looking
at ticks it's not going to be the same
as volume because again remember each
trade could be different volume but you
sort of have an idea I think someone
once released a sort of a calculator to
sort of give you an idea a rough idea of
you know how many ticks trade based off
of you know historical data but here
this is a 200 tick chart in the crude
right so it's giving you a bit more
signals then the 3 minutes so it just
leads me to believe it's probably a
little bit faster if you know you want
to look at volume okay yeah I don't know
750 volume
okay just type in
that
750 okay see here it's a little cleaner
a lot of Longs down here here was a
short here it was along
here you know even you if you want to
you say you like you're curious about
how it performs on you know how it looks
on a 10 range chart all right and you
want to add it to your chart okay
okay so this is 10 range right it's a
bit cleaner as well nice move up nice
move down uh well that's yesterday let's
take a look at today you know nice move
down here you know still catching this
pressure on the market here catches that
move now you know people sometimes will
ask well what if I want to have you know
um say a five
minute okay and you know I want to have
a 3 minute signals also what you do is
you just add another instance of it so
it's here and then what you're going to
do is you're going to change it from
minute first one is five change this one
to three and then you probably want to
change the color setup on
it you know make it green
and oh you already got red so maybe make
a deep
pink that way
you can have
both signals here right your red there's
your pink a little hard to see here's
your green oh sorry here's your green
here's your blue
okay if you want to I'm just saying you
can do that you know if you want to put
even multiple time frames on there and
you know say you know a 3 minute with a
5 minute you it just gives you the
option to see oh hey you know what
there's there's some aligned signals now
does that make it stronger again you'd
have to do that test um yourself so let
me just take off one of those I don't
want to confuse too many but you know
that's a way that you know say you want
you know because everyone I got a top
Town approach I look at the weekly the
daily the 12 hour the 6 hour the 3 hour
the 4 Hour 1 hour 30 minutes you know if
you want to add that extra layer that's
how you do it um
let's just take a look at uh I don't
know look at currencies first here 60
then we'll jump
into maybe a couple yeah this Market's
kind of yucky it's kind of very tight
range today all right but again you know
it catches the sell over here you see
we're coming down a little bit catches
the buy is is just a tight range
basically from 06 up to up to 20 21 so
not a not a big range um today but you
can see like on days like yesterday
where it's you know a nice trending day
catches this move down you know tries to
catches these buys here catches the rest
of the move down I think actually we we
were selling off a lot since the
overnight
session um you know the day before here
here shorts the sell buy didn't work out
you know then you're getting short up
here 57 down into you know the
30s It's Curious here it's a nice Trend
up got your buys up here got your short
in here
um what was that that was five minute or
three minute I forgot what I was looking
at five minute and again you know tick
if you want to look at a tick
chart or tick tick based chart signals
you just change it to tick here okay and
you see you're getting some nice bit
more signals there a bit more
aggressive again you know the S the
shorter you go the more aggressive it's
going to be okay 200 tick in the
eurocurrency actually not bad signals
said today is just kind of day just
going back and forth but it's you know
it's trying it's doing its best here um
let's take a look at M andq right
because I know there's a lot of M andq
guys out there now I I wouldn't use a
uh 200 tick chart uh signals on it
rather but we'll start with uh we just
start with the simple
base
chart
okay and take a look you know it's like
got that big push
down from about 1: in the morning till
about 3: then we rallied back
up towards that high and we come back
down towards that low right now it's
just it's doing the calculation here um
prob you know with if you're changing
your chart on a market has a lot of dat
data M andq has a lot of data cuz
obviously it covers a lot of price it
will be
slower than you know a market like euro
currency okay so this is just the simple
base chart okay let me just open it up
so it's a little easier to see one
minute chart and you know there's some
decent signals right you honestly I'm
not going to lie you know from
19950 here down obviously short short
short short short buys you know this
that's
over 150 points right there you know
catches some of the bigger moves okay
but you know that's all well and good
but you know you probably want to clean
it up right if you could catch imagine
you if you're scalping on a shorter time
frame and you could see signals that are
coming in based off of a higher time
frame which do you think is going to be
stronger well you know we can sit here
and we can debate it but uh like I was
talking about earlier you know
information that's obviously derived
from a higher time frame and is
generally you think is going to be
stronger Now problem was there wasn't a
way before to put those signals
onto your lower time
frame now there
is right so
imagine you can start trading the 5
minute signal I mean obviously the bars
you know it's got to do its analysis
over the 5 minutes but it's going to
plot it on your one minute you could
manage the trade a lot better in my
opinion okay so here it's a lot cleaner
now look at that right you still
catching that big move down the move
back up you now you're not getting
chopped up with those little sell
signals in here
right um where's the cash open this is
the cash open you know we pop back up
then you got your sell signal off this
high right
here you know from basically what's
called
1900 you know Jesus down to 800 it's 100
Point move in the NASDAQ in 30
minutes more or
less um you know it it's it's just in my
opinion it just adds a whole new
dimension to to trading
okay now again if if you already have
the Delta scalper you're should have
gotten an email for the upgrade if
you're interested in getting the delta
scalper
go
to Deltas scaler.com let me put the link
up in here okay where is
it right here Deltas scaler.com okay and
again you know I'm I'm trying to
schedule a time to do a more thorough
in-depth uh training of the Delta
scalper it will probably be next week
and again if so look for your emails or
I'm going to actually
I'll when I announce the webinar for
that I'm going to put a uh I'll put a
special video together announcing it
with a link that you can go to uh sign
up for you know for those guys those of
you that following me on YouTube but on
my email list um so that you could you
could watch it because again you know I
don't want to go too much in depth on it
right now because
it's kind of not complex but you know
there's a lot of different markets out
there that people trade and you know I'm
sure I'll get a lot of requests hey can
show me this chart show me this chart
show me this chart um you know know this
time frame that time frame that doing it
like on a video like this right now I I
can go on for three hours showing you
just different examples but anyway guys
um you know Delta scalper is a great
tool it allows you to read
orderflow on your existing bar chart so
again you know click the link below to
get started and I'll see you guys on the
inside take care